Quiero preguntarle en principio a nivel
regulatorio
a nivel regulatorio que implica esta
declaración de la OMS porque llama la
atención por ejemplo qué va a pasar con
las patentes de las vacunas
Bueno antes de eso es muy importante
señalar que
al haber definido la OMS que no estamos
ya en una emergencia sanitaria de
trascendencia internacional no ha dicho
que se ha acabado la pandemia eso es muy
importante subrayarlo no ha dicho que el
virus haya dejado de circular lo que ha
hecho es ajustarse a los procedimientos
del reglamento sanitario internacional
para
reducir la intensidad de las medidas en
la en la medida en que estamos en una
situación en donde la vacunación y las
coberturas que hemos alcanzado nos
permiten tener pues una mayor
flexibilidad en las medidas restrictivas
y de protección pero no es el fin de la
pandemia Entonces desde un punto de
vista regulatorio bueno el tema de la de
las patentes Lamentablemente aún en una
emergencia sanitaria internacional no
prosperó lo suficiente como para
permitir el acceso universal y sin
barreras de patentes a todos los países
que tenían que beneficiarse de la vacuna
o de medios terapéuticos o diagnósticos
para la pandemia bueno tras enfrentar
una situación como la pandemia de
covid-19 con toda la tecnología
desarrollada es más sencillo rastrear e
identificar tempranamente patógenos que
puedan generar una situación similar
no hemos aprendido muchas cosas y hemos
desarrollado nuevas tecnologías muy
particularmente relacionadas con las
vacunas pero no quiere decir que ahora
tengamos Todo bajo control tenemos un
riesgo de futuras pandemias que está en
el aire que tenemos que
minimizar a través de preparativos
adecuados para las pandemias de
vigilancia muy estrecha Especialmente
del Salto de de patógenos de animales a
seres humanos y tenemos que tener planes
de contingencia para que no nos pille
desprevenida una pandemia como nos
ocurrió con el caso de Kobe 19 en la
actualidad hay algún patógeno que
represente un riesgo similar a lo que
ocurrió con el
yo creo que debemos distinguir aquí
entre nuevos patógenos que no conocemos
que podrían surgir por un salto de
especies animales a humanas y entonces
no tenemos el conocimiento de ello pero
tenemos la noción Clara y el Coby lo ha
ilustrado de lo que puede generar una
una infección de esa naturaleza dando
lugar a una pandemia Pero tenemos
también virus o agentes patógenos como
es el caso del virus de la influenza que
la influenza aviar si tuviese un salto a
mamíferos y hubiese una transmisión
entre humanos podría situarnos en un
riesgo pandémico semejante a lo que
hemos visto con la pandemia de
Bueno usted lo estaba mencionando antes
y es que hay unas lecciones pero no todo
está prendido realmente el mundo está
preparado para enfrentar las futuras
pandemias que pueden llegar
el mundo no está preparado el mundo
necesita hacer muchos mucho más esfuerzo
para estar preparado y e invertir en
mayor grado todos los países del orbe en
estos momentos Incluso el comité
independiente que evaluó la gestión de
la pandemia un año después de que esto
ocurriese que estaba presidido por la
ex primer ministra de Nueva Zelanda y la
expresidenta de Liberia acaba de lanzar
un marco de actuación para mejorar la
preparación pandémica en el mundo y yo
creo que esto es algo que tiene que ser
discutido en los ámbitos de la asamblea
general de las Naciones Unidas de la
asamblea Mundial de la Salud tener un
esfuerzo multilateral y apoyarse en un
esfuerzo muy decidido país por país para
reforzar las capacidades que nos
permitan contender mejor con una posible
futura pandemia